what has been almost a month now since
governor sisal acts directive to close
non-essential business here in Nevada
and Las Vegas mayor Carolyn Goodman is
now speaking out urging the governor to
reopen our economy soon
Hector Mejia is live on the strip with
the mayor's comments good morning to you
Hector good morning Alex shops and
resorts are closed here we have the
encore right behind us and the mayor
says it's her belief that the corona
virus is not going away anytime soon and
therefore these places should reopen
mayor Carolyn Goodman made remarks
during yesterday's City Council meeting
on March 17th
governor steve says elect issued a
directive closing all non-essential
businesses including casinos to slow the
spread of corona virus he joined several
other governor's in that decision our
tourism industry has been on hold since
then while Goodman sent her condolences
to families who have lost loved ones to
coated 19 she also emphasized those
debts quote caused the entire state to
shut down from my perspective I am
asking open the city open Clark County
open the state for heaven's sakes for
being closed is killing us already and
killing Las Vegas our industry our
Convention and tourism business that we
have all worked so hard to build the
longer we wait to do this the more
impossible it will become to recover
she said 900,000 Nevadans are out of
work so far almost 300,000 have filed
for unemployment according to the
governor and we reached out to his
office a couple of times yesterday and
so far we have not received a response
back reporting live this morning Hector
Mejia 8 News now